thank you
hey Barbie
can I come to your house tonight
I don't have anything they planned just
a giant blowout party with all the
Barbies and plant choreography in a
bespoke song you should stop by so cool
congratulations on the movie I really
resonated with Barbie and Ken's Journey
about like feeling like they have to be
perfect and like living up to
expectations that aren't even really
their own and I was wondering if there
was a time in your career where you felt
that way personally that made you like
connect to Ken and Barbie you know in
making this movie I definitely felt that
way not just in like my portrayal of
Bobby but well anytime I've played
someone like when I played Holly Quinn
and I know there's a lot of Harley Quinn
fans out there you just like want to do
the character Justice like I know how
much it means to me when a character I
love is going to be brought to life for
the first time on screen and I would
always hate it when like the act of
playing that character would be like no
I didn't read the book or whatever and
I'm like those books mean a lot to me I
really wish you would you know um so I
know what it's like to have that kind of
expectation for a character if you're a
fan of that character but I also
recognize that in the case to Bobby
there's a lot of people who have a real
issue with Barbie and I also wanted us
to be having a conversation with those
people too and then I also wanted to
have a conversation with the people who
feel indifferent about Barbie where
Barbie doesn't even register in their
life and never has and up until this
movie hopefully it hadn't but this might
change things so
I don't know I guess yeah I definitely
felt a certain sense of expectation and
pressure around just delivering this
movie and and wanting it to hit so many
people this film for sure you know it
was such a I mean Margot had created
this whole opportunity for everyone and
you know she had been working on this
for years and then obviously
Greta had written like the best script
I'll probably ever read and it just felt
so perfect everything was like just this
this like tonal Symphony and I was uh
you know didn't want to be the one thing
Out Of Tune you know so it was it was
definitely a lot of pressure to sort of
it felt like a huge
gift that they had given me and so I
wanted to sort of you know
fired I'm fired no you were doing so
okay good because Margo wrote that from
me
well you definitely hit the right Mouse
you're definitely
and this is the greatest version of Ryan
Gosling on screen I know that you said
that like you killed it was like Mickey
Mouse Club kennergy was everything I
wanted to ask both of you though have
you ever been called Barbie or Ken in
real life and did you ever did you
reflect on that while working on this
project do you know what's so funny is
I've worked so Kate McKinnon plays our
weird Bobby in the in the movie Kate
McKinnon and I worked together on
bombshell and in one take and bombshell
which actually made the cut of the movie
uh you know my characters just like been
revamped because she best do her first
on camera thing and I come out and she
goes wow anchor Barbie and I it made the
move it's in the movie and so yeah it
came McKinnon's called me Barbie before
I've never gotten Ken I don't think uh
I don't think anyone ever saw this
but you and Greta yeah
so
I don't know I know I've never been
really no one's ever said that to you
what's that I guess it's not really a
thing you say like Ugh you're such a
candle but never Brian yeah
as in people getting your name yeah
never can
oh because they're our favorite surprise
I love you both so much thank you for
making this to me thank you for just
even if I may be superficial for a
moment you look incredible this outfit
is everything thank you your validation
is the only one I need
it
what do I have to do you have to go to
the real world
go back to your regular life or you can
know the truth about the universe
choice is
n't that the first one the high heel you
have to want to know okay do it again
congratulations on the movie you guys
killed it it's so funny you know Kate we
know you
and Barbie
Michael you play Alan which is this
Barbie doll that came out in the 1960s
and Alan always kind of like lived in
Ken's Shadow I felt like like he could
wear the same clothes as Ken but after
watching this movie I was like Alan's
cooler than you think so do you guys
think Alan's cooler than Ken I can't do
that
moves yeah honestly
he's done Alan Peaks at 45. Alan knows
how to make an omelette he does skill
piece yeah that's kind of yeah
his children are in middle school
they're doing really well is that a good
time to pee yeah it is I think so 45
yeah
no
a lot of doors a lot of doors are closed
but he made he made good choices along
the way and now he's reaping there you
can enjoy it all downhill he'll enjoy
his 40s a lot more than Ken will he sure
will yeah that was the point of that
yeah he's winning for one little moment
in time at least did you feel like Alan
was cooler than
well I feel
I feel Shot the movie Alan is sort of um
very invested in Ken you know he exists
kind of through Ken's wins or his wins
and Ken's losses or his losses so he's
on a wild ride he's you know he's just
strapped in for the for the emotional
roller coaster of Ken's experience I
loved Alan just for Alan do you think
that we did weird Barbie and Alan vote
for president Barbie and what is it true
I think of these constituents thank you
Issa Ray truly yes you think Allen voted
for president what about you
oh yes
you put them on the spot and I don't
feel like I'm getting them are you
probably unanimous yeah it feels like
you're the only choice
yeah okay I got it I don't know if
you've probably voted
I'm sorry
I voted I vote but weird Barbie I feel
like she might have just like forgot she
honestly seems so
and no offense to her like not
disrespectful she feels so desperate for
approval that she would vote uh-huh but
I don't remember that was just
you know she TR she tries to appear
lackadaisical about most things but
she's like Civic engagement is an
important Bedrock of ours for sure our
world yeah absolutely she's kind of like
the Grinch of Barbie
she's still very pleasant yeah what does
President Barbie think about Allen I
think that President Barbie wishes that
Alan would would be more involved in the
community because he's always at a
distance and I'd have to say that
playing her while Alan was at a distance
I could I would always break because his
voice was so soft and far away he's
never truly a part of the conversation
and I think the best presidents want to
include everyone I think Alan would be
honored that the president had any
awareness of him
I think that's a huge honor
kind of music
Barbie in the real world that's
impossible if this got out this could be
an extremely weird things for our world
catastrophic America there's a monologue
that you say in this movie that I
resonated with so much about how hard it
is to be a woman and I was wondering
what was everyone's reaction to you
saying that on set and what was it like
for you saying it yeah it was an intense
couple of days we shot that scene for
two days because it's inside of like the
bigger weird Barbie scene and there's a
ton of people in the scene
um
so I did that speech for like two days
and that was
um a marathon uh it was
I remember it being really
intense you should ask them I asked but
Margo was there and Kate McKinnon was
there but I remember it being like
um
a lot of
like it like I think it really landed
with the crew too like I had a lot of
crew members men and women approach me
and they were like really
um felt it but I mean I remember reading
the script and it just it at once being
like wow this is what a gift that Greta
and Noah are giving to you know to an
actor to get to to deliver this but also
in the next breath feeling like
um intimidated because that's a you know
it's it's also you want to do it justice
and so it was it was wonderful
Greta gave me so much permission to
explore I did a million different
versions of it and I just trusted that
like she would know what was right for
the movie and and so I felt safe to kind
of try everything and and we did we we
did it a million different ways when you
nailed it I got really emotional and I
felt like that hadn't been articulated
so perfectly in that way and I love that
you like delivered it and I just love
your character's name Gloria uh if it
felt like her name was in reference to
Gloria Steinem and I know you met Gloria
Steinem in 2016. did you think about
Gloria at all when you were embodying
your own character I thought about so
many women embodying Gloria
um I thought about myself I thought
about the women in my family I thought
about all of my friends all the women I
love women I know women I don't know and
just like
what it takes to get to be our whole
selves and yeah I think I I
held with me like a lot of different
um Inspirations and women I um that's an
interesting thought about Gloria Steinem
I don't know you have to ask Greta if
there's any any connection there I
remember last time we spoke you were
telling me about how growing up you
didn't feel like you really resonated
with Barbie or felt like you belonged in
Barbie's World and now you have your own
Barbie and I saw it and I was like I
wonder how America's feeling right now
how did you feel like looking at your
own Barbie and having it yeah I mean it
it it's surprising and deeply unexpected
I mean
I I I never ever imagined I would be in
a Barbie movie
um but it's not just about being in a
Barbie movie it's the way that I get to
be in the movie I get to be in the movie
as a human
person
with all that I am
um and and what that says to me is that
things have changed things have improved
you know I I there is this deeply
dominant narrative and and and
stereotype of Beauty in the Barbie
um
you know narrative that just didn't
include me when I was growing up people
like me and to get to be a part of a
moment that's expanding that narrative
for so many people is so unexpected to
me and and also just a joy that I get to
be a part of of making that world
include more of us
it's the best day ever it is the best
day ever so is yesterday and so is
tomorrow and every day pronouncing
forever
you guys ever think about dying
Greta Gerwig hi hi so such a pleasure to
meet you I know that you got to work
with Mattel and for their offices yeah
and when you were doing that you noticed
that most of their dolls were named
Barbie yes and I was wondering how you
picked which Barbies would make it into
the movie like mermaid Barbie and
president Barbie because she's had over
200 occupations like rap musician Barbie
yes American Idol winner Barbie Arctic
rescue Barbie I mean there were some
constraints in terms of like I wanted
like you know NASCAR winning Barbie like
I wanted all the you at a certain point
people are like we can't shoot this
movie forever so I had to you know pick
and choose but um I was just sort of
astonished by when I did when I did go
to Mattel and they and they did explain
to me that like Barbie is now occupied
the self of Barbie occupies all these
women and I was like oh that is so
fascinating and interesting as an idea
and what about Ken and they were like
the same thing is true of Ken I was like
great well that seems like a really
surreal real place to start yeah
um you nailed it because there's some
special Barbies in the movie that I
don't want to give away that just made
me laugh so hard oh good yeah I also
wanted to ask you about Gloria yes
because I wanted to know if her name was
in reference to Gloria Steinem at all
based on the journey that she goes on in
the movie
um well I you know that's so interesting
I didn't even think of that um I um I
think in a way I haven't had the
privilege of of having daughters but I
get to name characters and I've always
loved the name Gloria it's one of my
favorite names and um I I gave the name
um of Gloria to Gloria and I remember
actually when we were working on the
movie and I was I was kind of putting it
together and then somebody said um about
Gloria they said oh she had referencing
Her speech they said it's the Gloria
Arya
um and I was like the Gloria Arya that's
perfect it is like an aria like it's
almost like it's sung so I thought well
that's the right name it it just it just
um names are mysterious but yeah I also
had it
um a Gloria in my life who I loved so
you know I love that oh I gotta tell you
wrote that speech out so perfectly I
talked to her about that oh she's
amazing how everyone felt and it had
never been articulated in that way and I
got emotional yeah hearing that so thank
you so much for writing about how hard
it is to be a woman also though I was
gonna say I should say but I named it
after Gloria Steinem because that's a
much smarter answer
I mean it's still from now on because
that that that's very um I wish I had
thought of that but um yeah America also
just um she brought I mean when we
started working on the character and
working on uh that section she she also
brought a lot of her herself and her
perspectives into it and like she made
it hers in a way that when she performed
it everybody on set just cried all day
because when she was doing it it was
like
she was speaking it felt like she was
speaking for everybody and there was
something about it where I was just like
if it makes this group of people in on
the stage and men too yeah feel what
they felt I think it will make audiences
feel that too and um anyway I I mean
I've seen it hundreds of times and it
still gets me